okay so we're all leaving for the
hospital at one o'clock so five
free entry i can take three
[Laughter]
we're leaving for the hospital at one
the freedom tree
sorry let's just go through that part
okay we're leaving for the hospital at
one like a freedom treat
we should plant a tree
oh good at least we don't have to work
okay we're leaving for the hospital at
one so like a freedom tree i can take
three people i can also take three
people now i know what you're thinking
won't that just shed more light on the
penises but you know what
that's a risk
we have today
that
that is a risk that we have to no no no
i know what you're saying why don't you
keep going
hey i know what you're thinking
won't that just [ __ ]
i know what you're thinking won't that
just shed more light on the penises but
that is a risk we need to take
pam thank you
pam why don't you work with ballast and
draw a picture of the exposure
this is a petition for the business park
to upgrade their security cameras as
well as install two floodlights in the
parking lot no no i know what you're
thinking
won't that just shed more light on the
penises
but that is a risk we have to take pam
you can draw kind of why don't you work
with phallus on drawing a picture of the
exposure that i can post around the
community phallus phyllis sorry
i've got penises on the brain
so see i will end up having your little
butt in jail and what they will do to
you is nothing compared to what i'll do
to you before you get down there you are
not to be ready
that little girl is a child i don't want
to see you sniffing around her anymore
this afternoon do you understand yes boy
have you lost your mind cause i'll help
you find it what you're looking for
ain't nobody gonna help you out there
jesus can come through that door and
he's not gonna help you if you don't
stop sniffing after my child okay i
guess what surround sound means is that
right over here
two speakers
damn
we have two speakers
what
honey oh jesus
this is terrible
never finish this episode
check this out
folds
sorry oh my god i finally
broke down and bought myself
a plasma
tv
check it out i actually hung this on the
wall myself that's good i want to show
you something a lot of people in the
room you need more space
voila right into the wall wow i want my
baby back baby baby baby i want my baby
back
back i want my baby
[Music]
[Laughter]
baby back ribs
chilies
chilies baby back ribs
no wait out the second one okay
[Laughter]
did somebody say baby back ribs
um
i don't think christian has time for
that i have time
i want my baby i want my baby
[Music]
within the workplace
[Laughter]
go ahead you do it
okay i insist
basically after phil's blackmailed
angela michael asked them both to step
down from the party planning committee
because there was too much drama what he
said was easy there
was a problem with having one head of
the party planning committee she becomes
too powerful so he appointed two heads
party planner this is literally the
stupidest
humiliating
that's
on my side
so this is fun
5k means 5 kilometers you put 5 000
miles on this flyer
come in
hey oh my god
oh
yeah what no
michael stay you said come in
oh my god
michael
5k means 5 kilometers not 5 000 miles
hey hey oh my god what are you doing you
said come in no i didn't just oh my god
please
what happened to foreign it's okay two
minutes is too soon five minutes and two
minutes is a very big difference
together right now
[Music]
[Laughter]
i told you like five minutes well what
happened to four and three because two
minutes doesn't do us any good come here
no what chicago
how are we doing on contractions two
minutes apart two minutes
oh god
oh my god i told you it's okay no i told
you to warn me at five minutes jim we
waited too long i know we waited too
long two minutes doesn't do us any good
well what happened to porn okay jim
phyllis did i or did i not say fruit
you did say fruit and what is that
cake and what did i say
fruit
is this funny to you phyllis
she's nervous
yeah well she should be nervous because
i'm about to kick her ass
i'm gonna walk in again
okay everybody phyllis
did i or did i not say fruit you said
fruit michael and what is that
cake
you don't really toss the dough
try to destroy the old ways gabe i will
not let you do
[Laughter]
it okay you don't really toss the dough
try to destroy the old ways gabe i will
not let you
when it came out for soccer practice
i i pinched him
where did you pinch him
what's the very very worst thing about
prison don't encourage him dwight the
worst thing about prison was that was
the dementors they
were flying all over the place and they
were scary and then they come down and
they suck the soul out of your body and
then height three sex
or a heavy padding closets one
masturbation closet
does anyone have a problem with that
yes gay closet five that wasn't like
five shots no that's that wasn't the
problem three heavy padding closets one
masturbation closet and one gay class
absolutely yes i don't no problem
everybody happy with the glory holes
what
well i heard about somewhere holy fifth
closet will have a glory hole
[Laughter]
we're going to designate one of our
closets as a hookup zone anything goes
just leave it high michael that's absurd
what if two couples want to go at the
same time okay then we have two classes
no no we're gonna have three closets
one for each base no homers yes and what
is the hook-up zone policy on
masturbation
pro yes
what
you